tonight we have a development in our
ongoing exclusive investigation into the
behavior of Google there are new emails
first obtained by this show now Google
as you know is the most powerful company
in the history of the world virtually
all human information flows to its
software and for that reason in Google
shapes much of how the world understands
reality at the heart of Google's
business is its search engine which has
a virtual monopoly on search in this
country and others Google search
succeeds because it is blindingly
efficient but also because it is
perceived as honest when you search for
a term on Google the most popular
results come to the top the process is
straightforward and democratic that's
what most people think that's how it's
perceived and that's why the world
trusts Google but what if Google was
lying to you one of the results that you
got were secretly waited to get you to
vote a certain way to believe a certain
thing that would affect a lot of people
and a lot of votes in fact it would be
impossible to have a real democracy
under circumstances like that a small
number of incredibly rich people would
be in charge of everything including
your perceptions well that is a major
concern for all of us because Google is
a very political company we recently
showed you email evidence of a Google
effort to collude with a left-wing group
in support of Hillary Clinton's
presidential campaign now tonight we
have internal documents that show that
Google employees discussed corrupting
the company's search engine to push
propaganda on hundreds of millions of
unsuspecting users here's what happened
shortly after taking office President
Trump issued his now-famous travel ban
almost immediately after that Google
employees began plotting ways to
undermine the president's executive
order On January 29th a Google product
marketing manager named Mackenzie Thomas
sent an email to a group of fellow
employees quote there is a large brain
storm going on throughout the marketing
orgs she wrote brainstorming about how
to respond to Trump's order among
Thomas's ideas was quote to actively
counter algorithmically biased results
for search terms such as Islam Iran
Mexico Latino and so forth in other
words Google employees wanted to alter
the search results to make them more
positive in certain cases for political
reasons Thomas
also suggested promoting links for
making donations to organizations
fighting the travel ban this of course
would be completely dishonest and
unethical behavior but Thomas's
colleagues at Google seemed to approve
of it strongly product manager Rami Bona
for example replied this way quote we're
absolutely in Mackenzie anything you
need we'll put together a list of orgs
with marylin HL team another employee
named Stacey Chen added that group she
thought Google should promote included
the ACLU the defect the immigration
defense project the arab-american
anti-discrimination committee and the
National Immigration Law Center all of
those groups were at the time agitating
against the president's immigration ban
even at least one person on the chain
seemed to realize how dangerous and out
of the ordinary this conversation was a
Google employee called Clement wolf
commented that he was quote very much in
favor of Google stepping up but was
wondering quote how partisan we want to
be on this to the extent of my knowledge
would be breaching precedent if we only
gave highlights access to organizations
to support a certain view we contacted
Google about these remarkable emails and
the reply to us is here in full quote
these emails were just a brainstorm of
ideas none of which were ever
implemented Google has never manipulated
its search results or modified any of
its products to promote a particular
political ideology not in the current
campaign season not during the 2016
election and not in the aftermath of
president Trump's executive order on
immigration our processes and policies
would not have allowed for any
manipulation of search results promote
political ideologies end quote left
unanswered by Google was why anyone
would believe that statement for a
second nor did Google say anything about
the employees on that email chain
presumably they still work at Google
which is remarkable if you ran a bank
and caught your tellers brainstorming
about how to rob the vault would they
still work for you remember that Google
fired an engineer called James Day more
last summer almost instantly the CEO
flew back from a family vacation to fire
him why because damar was caught
expressing mildly conservatives ideas in
a private memo here Google employees are
plotting to subvert our entire public
conversation secretly but that's fine
with Google
it shouldn't be fine with any of us or
with the US Congress Huell executives
are scheduled to testify on Capitol Hill
next week the scheduled topic is privacy
but it would be nice of at least one
elected representative asked about this
because it's much scarier than anything
Russia ever attempted Peter Schweitzer
wrote Clinton cash you know is a
fantastic new documentary called the
creepy line about big tech and he joins
us tonight are you surprised by this not
really it's just further confirmation
that Google has been cooking the books
as it relates to search and you're
absolutely right I mean this would be
like a company having a brainstorming
session on how we're gonna fiddle with
the books and in in accounting then
you're gonna step back and say no we
were just having a brainstorming session
it speaks to the culture of the company
and the culture of the company is they
are prepared to put their thumb on the
scale and shift the debate in favor of
the direction that they want to go but
this is so corrupt it is I was stunned
by it and I was worried that these
emails were not authentic because it's
such a big so Church is the core of
Google's business it's many different
things as Google but basically it's a
search engine was built on the back of
one yeah and the promise has always been
that they're not lying to you right but
they are that's right and this is really
the third strike as far as I'm concerned
the first strike of course is the
commercial search when travel websites
and and people like Yelp were
complaining that they were you know
tilting the algorithm yes against them
to others Google said absolutely not we
would never do that we now know the
Federal Trade Commission the EU and
others had looked at this and said
Google was fiddling with the algorithm
the second strike as far as I'm
concerned was the work done by dr.
Robert Epstein yeah shows clearly in
2016 that search was tilted to favor
Hillary Clinton this is strike three it
shows that the culture of the company is
such that they're very happy having a
free and open conversation about
manipulating the algorithm on a highly
polished and I mean so people go to jail
for violating our campaign and finance
laws because they put an extra ad on
some cable channel nobody watches this
is the most powerful company in the
world that's right how can we have a
democracy in a country where Google can
just get whoever it wants elected by
lying to us through the search function
it's a great example
Tucker of regulations and campaign
finance laws not keeping up at all with
where we are in technology nobody were
too consumed when we pass laws about
in-kind contributions to campaign from
companies that something like this would
happen but this is the ultimate the
ultimat campaign contribution this is
not like you know X on giving gasoline
to a political campaign this is a
company secretly tipping the scales in
favor of candidates or causes or beliefs
that they have it's done in secret we
don't know how it how expensive it's
happening and eighty to ninety percent
of search in the world is basically done
through Google's so they have complete
dominance in this area and the Congress
does nothing and I can think of at least
one Republican senator who I believe has
been bought off by Google I don't think
he's alone yeah at some point it might
be worth naming who those people are
Peter great to see you thanks Tucker